these are dark musings and I would say
how much of the antipathy towards men
that's being generated by say
college-age women is deep repugnance for
the role that they've been designed and
a disappointment with the man who you
know like you think of those carpathian
or I can't remember the culture the
basic merit marital routine was to ride
into the village and grab the bride and
run away with her on a horse right it's
like the like the motorcycle gang member
who rips the two naive woman out of girl
out of the bosom of her family there
used to be bride stealing it was quite
quite quite widespread right now so I
kind of wonder if part of the reason
that modern university aged women aren't
so aren't so angry is because that
fundamental feminine role is actually
being denied to them and they're they're
objecting to that at a really really
fundamental level like a level of
primitive outrage well because what
happened is the chaos that my generation
of 1960s bequeathed through the sexual
revolution I went when I arrived in
college 1964 the colleges were still
acting in local parentis in place of a
parent so at my dormitory were all
women's dormitory we women had to sign
in at 11 o'clock at night the men could
run free the entire night so it was my
generation of women that rose up and
said give us the same freedom as men
have and the colleges replied no in the
world is dangerous that you could be
raped we have to protect you against
rape and what we said okay was give us
the freedom to risk rape okay and so
that what that today's women to
understand it's a freedom that you want
it's the same freedom to give gay men
have when they go and they pick up a
stranger someplace they know it's
dangerous they know they could end up
beaten up or killed okay but they find
it hat if you want freedom if you want
equality okay then you have to start
behaving like a man no so what we did is
we gave freedom to these young women for
several generations but my generation
had been raised in a far more resilient
arroba
culture okay we had the strength okay ii
didn't know what we wanted and to fight
for what we wanted these young women
have been raised in this protective
terribly protected ways so I think in
some strange you know the fashion that
that all these demands for intrusion
from these you know Stalinist committees
sexual you know investigating dates and
so on it's a way to reinstitute tooken a
the rules that my generation through out
the window I saw I think these young
women are desperate not only that but I
have spoken out very strongly in you
know in a in a piece I wrote for Time
magazine that isn't my most recent book
that the raising the drinking age in
this country okay from 18 to 21
okay this had a direct result okay in
these in these disasters of binge
drinking fraternity parties because it's
a lotta let Constance the way we could
go out as freshmen have a beer sit in a
protected adult environment learn how to
discourse with the opposite sex in a
safe
you know man environment right and so on
and you in not today okay because
because of the stupid rule that young
people can't even buy a drink okay you
know in a bar until they're 21 we have
these the fraternity parties that are
like it's a caveman era well of course
in this modern age if this advantages
men okay men want to hook up and then
want to have sex women don't understand
what men want so you know if women women
are like put out because they're hoping
that maybe the man lookin to be
interested in them okay the man just
wants experience okay I mean that the
hormones drive toward turning to me
I've theorized okay that the you know
they that the sex drive in men is
intertwined with with hunted pursuits
okay yes yes I feel absolutely this is
what women don't understand okay and if
women understood what I understand for
my transgender perspective alright with
these women on the streets okay you know
I you know I'm obviously you know but
Madonna you know an admirer and you know
and I support pornography and
prostitution so I don't want what I'm
about to say to seem conservative it
isn't okay what I'm saying is the women
on the street young women okay who are
but who are jogging okay with no bra on
okay short shorts and have and have
earbuds in their ears okay just jogging
the long long as I said these women do
understand the nature of the human mind
they do not understand the nature of
psychosis okay and this intertwining
them talking about of the hunt the
hunted pursuit eating okay they're
triggering a hunt thing just what you
would you you have talked about in terms
of the zebra herd okay
they are triggering the hunt game
impulse okay
in psychotic men okay there goes a very
appetizing and and and totally oblivious
animal okay bouncing along here okay
sorry and we're in a period now where
psychosis is not understood at all okay
yeah young women have had no exposure to
movies like psycho okay well you know
the kind of the rapists serial murderer
things so on the kind of strange dynamic
that has to do with it with an assault
on their mother in manga you know in in
in the mind of the psychotic but I think
that is an incredible naivete these
young women are emerging and going to
college and in this like incredible dye
nation environment of you know orgiastic
sexual experience in fraternity houses
they're completely unprepared for it
right and and so you're getting all this
out racial feminist rhetoric has gotten
more and more extreme its portrayal of
men as even but in fact okay what we
have is a caste it's a it's a chaos in
the sexual realm the girls have not been
told anything real I mean in terms of
biological substrate them sexual no way
there's full of lies about what
constitutes consent to become something
that's essentially portrayed
linguistically as a sequence of
progressive contracts which you know is
it's well I think you know I've thought
for a while that we're living in the
delusional fantasy of a naive
thirteen-year-old girl thoughts
basically sums up our culture and I look
at all these sexual rules that permeate
the the the academia and I think two
things the first thing I think is well I
know because I was an alcohol researcher
for a long time and you know that 50% of
violent crimes are directly attributable
to alcohol so if you're murdered there's
about a 50% chance that you're drunk and
about a 50% chance that the person who
kills you is drunk and alcohol is the
only drug that we know
that actually amplifies aggression it
does that in laboratory situations plus
it's a great disinhibitor right so what
alcohol does is it it doesn't make you
oblivious to the future consequences of
your action because if you ask someone
who's drunk about the consequences of
something stupid they can tell you what
the consequences are but it makes you
not care and it does that because it's
technically an exile it a click like
barbiturates or like benzodiazepines and
it also has an activating property for
many people who drink so it's it's a
stimulant and a-- and an anxiety attack
at the same time in a very very potent
it's very potent for both of them and
you know we put young people together
and douse them in alcohol right at the
binge drinking level and then which also
interferes with memory consolidation
which of course makes things much more
complex and then we're surprised when
there are sexual misadventures and you
know and then it's also attributed
almost purely to the predatory element
that's that's part and parcel of
masculinity but a tremendous amount of
that is also naivety and stupidity you
know because we expect like 80 18 year
old guys especially the ones that aren't
that haven't been successful with girls
which is like eighty-five percent of
them because the successful men are a
very small percentage of men the
eighty-five percent who haven't been
successful with men or with women they
don't know what the hell they're doing
at all right and part of the reason
they're getting drunk is to garner up
enough courage to actually make an
advance you know and because I think
another thing that women don't
understand especially with regards to
young men is just exactly how petrifying
attractive woman who's of say somewhat
higher status actually is to a young guy
and there's lots of guys that write me
constantly and people that I've worked
with that are so terrified of women they
can't even talk to them it's very very
common well you know I take a very firm
position which is that I want college
administration's to stay totally out of
the social lives of the students right
if a crime is committed it should be
reported to the police I've been writing
that for 24 25 years now all right but
but it's not the business of any college
administration to take any notice okay
of what to students say to each other
say to each other
as well as do with each other okay I
want it totally
stop is fascism of the war yeah I agree
why it's it's I think it's fascism of
the worst time because it's an it's a
new kind of fascism you know it's it's
partly generated by legislation so they
like the title nine men memo that was
written in 2011 I recently got a copy of
that goddamn thing that was one
polluting bit of legislation that was
that memo basically told universities
that unless they set up a parallel court
system they were going to be denied
federal funding it is absolutely
unbelievable and I know I know this
shows there is no authentic campus
leftism I'm sorry it's a fraud okay
I mean you think the faculty should be
fighting the administration's tiny
federal regulation of you know how we're
supposed to behave on campus well how
can you be so how can you be so naive
and foolish to think that taking an
organization like the university which
already has plenty to do and forcing it
to become a pseudo legal system that
parallels the legal system could
possibly be anything but utterly
catastrophic it would mean you have to
know absolutely nothing about the legal
system and about the tremendous period
of evolution that produced what's
actually a stellar system and an
adversarial system that protects the
rights of the accused end of the end of
the victim and to replace that with an
ad-hoc bureaucracy that has pretty much
essentially the same degree of power as
the court system with absolutely none of
the training and none of the guarantees
when they're taking that piece that I
wrote about date rape it was in January
1991 Newsday got but there's the most
controversial thing I ever wrote in my
entire career I attacked the entire
thing and demand in the colleges stand
back and get out of the socialized of
the students so on and and people
reaction people try to recall they
called the president of the like
University try to get me fired
you can't believe hysteria okay I can
believe anything that says to women okay
the theme should be responsible for
their own choices is regarded as
reactionary are they kidding me
okay this is such a betrayal of
authentic feminism in my view well it's
the ultimate betrayal of authentic
feminism because it's it it's and the
invitation of all the things that you
might be paranoid about with regards to
the patriarchy back into your life right
it's an insistence that the most
intrusive part of the tyrannical King
come and take control over the most
intimate details of your life incredible
and the the assumption is that that's
going to make your life better rather
than worse right not to mention this
idea of you know there's the stages of
verbal consent as if as if your impulses
based in the body have anything to do
with words and so on I mean that's the
whole point isn't you know about sex
okay it's to abandon okay that you know
that part of the brain that's so that
you know and it traveled with words I
mean there's you see this it's actually
a marker of lack of social ability to
have to do that because if you're
sophisticated it's not like if you're
dancing with someone it's not like you
call out the moves right if you have to
do that well then your your your your
more worse than a neophyte right you're
an awkward neophyte and anybody with any
sense should get the hell away from you
and so if you're reduced to the point
where you have to verbally negotiate
every element of intimate interaction
then what a downer that the ass but what
I what an unbelievably what would you
call it naive in pathological view of
the manner in which human beings
interact